[Applause]
these students at the University of
Toronto are angry because the so-called
men's rights activist was speaking at
their college his words are hate speech
they said they stopped people like this
man from getting in to see the Lexus
the so-called men's rights advocate
speaking inside was Warren Farrell for
the first time in US history boys will
have less education than their dad
Farrell is an odd person to call
anti-woman he was actually an early
feminist movement leader here he is with
Gloria Steinem but as he learned more he
started to disagree with parts of modern
feminism I don't agree with the part of
feminism this says men are the
oppressors and women are the oppressed
that part of feminism is sick men are
running the government they run most
companies they make more money our dads
and our grandpa's they made sacrifices
to make more money and then the feminist
movement turned all of that sacrificed
on the part of men against men and they
haven't said you were discriminated
against men in your own way you were
obliged to earn more money or we
wouldn't even be thinking about marrying
it we wouldn't be thinking about having
children with you in his book the boy
crisis ferrule notes that both sexes
struggle today boys are almost 1/3 less
likely to get college degrees than girls
twice as likely to commit suicide why is
no one talking about this because we
have believed for the last 50 years that
men had all the privilege and men had
all the power men and boys started
falling behind when government began
subsidizing single mothers they tear the
family apart by giving the money to
mothers when fathers are absent and not
giving money to mothers when fathers are
present that policy part of the welfare
system created in the 60s helped lead to
more households without fathers Ferrell
says that hurts boys most why are boys
more affected than girls boys tend to
not have
many skills at developing friendships
and developing emotional connections and
so when the family connection breaks
apart it affects them more profoundly
than it does their sisters this 1989 CBS
interview captured the changing
attitudes after welfare programs started
I think I can make it as a single parent
but don't you think you might need help
in raising that baby from a man it
doesn't make any difference whether she
needs a man it makes a difference that
her children need a father what happens
when the kids don't have fathers
children do worse in 70 different areas
they're far more likely to be
disobedient delinquent drop out of
school
fathers are critical says Farrell
because men tend to parent differently
for example men roughhouse more with
kids why is that important roughhousing
creates so many skill sets the father's
creating a bond with the child so the
children don't mind the discipline
because the discipline is the price they
pay for more fun with dead people think
that mothers tend to be better parents
because on average they're more
attentive to children's needs mothers
are more empathetic as a rule to the
children than dads but an empathetic
parent does not create an empathetic
child an empathetic parent is someone
who's always thinking of the children's
needs which teach the children to always
have his or her needs thought of the
empathy is created by the father or the
mother requiring the child to think
about the father's needs the mothers
needs their brothers needs in fact he
says helping children too much is
harmful dr. Phil covered that in this
video clip
mom is rewriting your essay
to eat you need to start with mom I'm in
middle school I'm not my school yet you
want me to try let me try
moms are filled with love and they want
to make sure their children do well so
they often do for the children
dads are filled with love but the way
that dads love is to feel that I need to
love the children by having the children
learn how to do for themselves having
both an involved mother and father leads
to the best outcome for kids a
government summary of studies notes
children who live with their fathers are
more likely to have good physical and
emotional health to achieve academically
to avoid drugs violence and delinquent
behavior we need men to be involved in
the fathering role to a much greater
degree than they are and have been even
when we control for the amount of money
a father and mother earth children with
dads still doing much better